but I went out to Colorado in June of 85
and I was cool for like a year I was
cool I had money I was working I moved
to where were you working
Foot Locker oh okay but there's more to
that story too because you were at the
Foot Locker oh yeah
no I robbed the whole Mall because
before I left he was good he said he was
cool before I left Jersey in 85.
I was in the city a lot I was working on
the city as a farm a bartender and I met
these dudes that knew how to get IDs
up in the Bronx right okay so I would go
up there with them to buy ideas for
friends of mine and then one day the guy
goes listen for an extra 500 we'll give
you a credit card
insurance card for your car
it's out of here and I'm like bro let's
do it line it up so the guy would tell
me how they do it whatever the bank got
the card got made at the bank
okay this is how we stole credit cards
this is how deep it was let's say they
made a card for Andrew Schultz they made
two cards for Andrew Schultz one went to
Andrew and one went to me
so you're the connect to the bank with
your name on the car on every car and I
knew everything you did they would tell
me
he just because we had to wait for you
to use the card first so I would get the
call from them he just used it bang boom
once we use the card and it got traced
dirty in New York we shipped it out to
LA because the computer was too slow
so the computer would break into court
Doug you want to deal with the King of
Swing or you want to deal with the king
the computer would go so Monday if the
card got reported Tuesday it wouldn't
get to La till Friday so you had
Thursday you had Wednesday Thursday so
Monday was the East Tuesday was the
Midwest Wednesday was Mountain Time
Thursday was California so you had three
days
and then forget it they wouldn't you
could you I was I was considered under
level under the limit Thief
which is using the card under 50 because
they don't call in they would just put
it down and go chick chick so I was
eating Chinese food every day for lunch
you had a new credit card for years now
I would use the same one that one could
even be declined and I would use it
because they wouldn't run it
they used to print out yeah what was
that paper yeah they had a little paper
that they looked the carbon paper yeah
they said carbon paper and then you send
it to the credit card company it gets
the money from the bank so you had a
whole day before they even knew
oh it's crazy but you could go back to
that same Chinese spot once they find
out oh I went every day
bro
okay holy [__] so how long did the
credit card thing go well his name is
Joey and they're looking for a guy with
a different credit card then when I got
to Colorado I was fine
and then it's like what you said after
like two months I'm like yeah you get
itchy I was in Boulder which is a
college town yeah I'm like holy [__]
this is like stealing so I called my
butt and I go send me some cards out
right so he sent me some cards out and
there was one mall in Boulder
so I'm going in there every day and
buying [__] chains and jackets but at
the same time I'm applying for work like
a [__] [__] that I am so I applied
this [__] Foot Locker and they hire
me and after a month I'm like the top
salesman I could do that [__] with my
eyes closed
but a Chinese family came in one day to
buy sneakers for the whole family I
noticed had a yellow envelope
on the side of his wallet and he fell so
I picked it up on the back there was
like three grand cash in there I go what
do I do do I give it back to the family
I go [__] no I'm snoring Coke tonight
you snooze you lose bro these people
wouldn't leave it alone that's somebody
robbed them nobody robbed them they
dropped it
and they called the cops when the cops
came in and one cop looked at me goes
somebody's been using the credit card in
here and you fit the description I'm
like what oh what and then he came back
three days later
and he goes is that something you want
to tell me and I'm like no
and he came back like a week later and
he's like listen man we're getting the
sizes of the clothes together and
everything we're gonna come and arrest
you
and I'm like bro I don't know what the
[__] you're talking about so this went
on
this went on for about two weeks and I
said [__] this I'm going to San
Francisco anyway I want to go hang out
with a buddy of mine in San Francisco so
I had met this girl
so I leave I never got charged for the
credit card all right I go to San
Francisco for six months I go to Aspen
my my house was ready and then I live in
Aspen a house sitting for like
a year yeah and then in November of 86 I
decided to go back to Boulder with my
girlfriend
I'm living in Boulder everything is
going great
and one day again now
a year later
after the credit card thing like any up
and up I get him no I was never on the
up and up I get involved in the
kidnapping
okay okay are you ready for this yeah
Warren gets put out there looking for me
what's can you give us some details hold
on hold on I turned I waited three days
I turn myself in who's the cop
interviewing that oh [__] that's the
credit card cop but he was too stupid he
didn't remember me get the [__] out of
he just kept looking at me weird like so
now after I got arrested I had to go to
court and sit next to this [__]
and he would look at me and I kept
saying what is this [__] gonna
realize I was the one that used the
[__] credit card
he never real and now there was two
arresting offices one guy Jimmy Cola
that's my dog I still talked to him on
Facebook
was one of those dudes that was like you
know you have to go away shut the [__]
up man yeah shut the [__] up what the
[__] are you talking about you know you
get paid what an hour it'll take you a
little water pistol and go do what you
gotta do you know what I'm saying you
want to be a cop or you want to be a
[__] jerk off yeah this was a drug
deal amongst drug dealers yeah and
you're making it seem like yeah
shut the [__] up yeah everybody knew
what was involved here nobody got ripped
off here so your best bet in fact I
turned myself in I was yelling at him
I'm like you're arresting me to do your
[__] for doing your job taking drugs off
the streets
I'm gonna work it you know
I'm gonna go in there and work it as
much as I [__] can
so I'm like how can you arrest me I'm
[__] I'm taking drugs off the street
for you [__] how dare you yeah
and they're like Joey come on knock it
off